hey there's going on welcome to Brooklyn
New York
it's not the greatest place in the world
but it's where we live for now I'm
planning on moving to say more in I'm
just used to home which is New York but
I'm definitely want to move back out to
the Caribbean islands which is my you
know real nothing against America but
I'm just used to like the natural food
the natural water a natural air
everything is cleaning down there the
water is actually blue it's not green no
offence Orchard Beach what it is and
yeah you don't have grocery stores and
stuff like that open 24 hours but the
crime is down so it's not that bad
probably the only thing good in the hood
vitaminwater where's our endorsement
deal we can push you guys like ten years
now
video games the good news is in the hood
as long as you're cool with the people
nobody bothers you so and they can tell
whether or not you're from the hood or
not like I'm endangering the cameraman
everybody but as long as we're means I
we understand the environment so we know
the do's and don'ts it's like you get
this heightened sense of how to avoid
the danger and stay away from certain
people and we just do our thing here we
just live here we don't hang out here in
Brooklyn we want to hang out we're going
to Manhattan blah blah blah
where we live in the ghetto we're not a
part of it
that's funny the world's greatest game
responses in this apartment
it's service so we can usually members
and yumpire come over and pretty much
run sessions Marvel Street Fighter I
remember these guys alone before like 15
now these guys is like in their early
20s and stuff like that and they're all
world champions players like me I came
from Jersey so this is a lot further for
me but when I come down here this is
what we do we uh we we play we I guess
do a think tank we try to figure out the
best way to be the best at the games
that we play so with that in mind we
require each other it's like we couldn't
do it on our own
I bet chart goes to my best friend Ron
sixteen years ago I didn't know someone
could play so many games and beat so
many games and the house is also a lot
of other players like Claymore they all
were really good at different types of
games before I met your post I just
didn't know that somebody could own over
a thousand games physical games this was
before like a lot of these systems this
is like during SNES genesis six boy era
the most documented tournament wins for
a given team is 1111 achieve I am Clark
Adia members of Team apps competed and
live game enjoyment online competitions
and war record attempts we've been doing
this since 2003 how many people can
actually say their organisation has over
20-something players in Guinness Book of
World Record
you can imagine I was all right 7 8
years old and I was running around the
Bronx with my friends going to our key
to arcade playing the latest games
trying to get high scores and then you
know I got older I got married and my
wife was like what are you going to do
this forever and I was like pretty much
it she was like well I've got to put
food on the table so that's what I
incorporated it into a business